forget about vote by mail how about vote
by
jail Squad congresswoman aanna Presley
introducing a bill that would let people
convicted of a felony to vote in federal
elections including criminals currently
locked up Presley also wants to lower
the age at The Ballot Box by letting
16year olds
vote a historic brand new first of its
kind bill that will end the stain a
felony disenfranchisement in America and
guarant
the right to vote for incarcerated
informally incarcerated citizens our
bill is a reflection of bold Progressive
Democratic Values Republicans and the
Supreme Court stopping at nothing to
undermine voting rights and to exclude
black and brown folks from participating
in our democracy our justice system has
not been equally fair to all our
citizens denying people the right to
vote they're paying their price
if they're in
jail you know uh
Jesse uh you know criminals are bad but
let's be honest 16-year-olds are worse
we can't let 16-year-olds vote that's
like they don't even have their brains
aren't even formed I
agree you have to be it's a prefrontal
cortex that's right you have to be 18 to
enlist buy a pet get a tattoo get a
lottery ticket or sign a contract you
have to be 21 to adopt the child buy
tobacco by alcohol by weed or gamble 16
is way tooly you can change your gender
at six that's true yeah so now if you're
in prison my all my prison pen pals yeah
that I that have been writing me and
then I write two back and send them
photos yes they say they can't wait to
get out of prison to vote for Trump and
you don't believe me so I think it
should just be left to the states and if
you do serve your time if you come out I
believe you should have the right to
vote and that's all I have to say about
that to quote the judge aren't they
trying to expand their base Beyond you
know dead people well yeah they they it
tells me that they're losing their base
without telling you that they're losing
their base I have a couple of thoughts
first of all you want to reduce the
voting age to 16 but they which means
that you have enough of a cognitive you
know uh uh formation that you can decide
who should be you know president who
should be this who should be that but um
you shouldn't be responsible for
criminal activity they keep raising the
age of young people to be charged with a
crime but now they want to lower it for
you to be able to vote which makes no
sense uh but but I think that the most
important thing is this issue of felons
being able to vote there are some states
where a felon cannot vote depending upon
the severity of the conviction you've
got like Wyoming Alabama abama Tennessee
Virginia Arizona but then there are
other states like Vermont which says
even if you're convicted of a felony you
can vote so the states are different in
New York you have to ask maybe for a
certificate of relief from disabilities
where the Court gives you the ability to
to to vote again but honestly I believe
even though I'm a prosecutor and I was
always the one looking to put them in
jail once they serve their time they
should be entitled to vote now Democrats
have to be careful what they wish for
they're assuming that if you're in jail
you're going to vote for the Democrats
except that's not working out because a
lot of people in jail are going to vote
for Donald Trump and I really believe
that a lot of that has to do with the
fact that they feel that they've been
unjustly handled by the justice system
and so has Donald Trump felons for Trump
yes and so and so you've got you've got
the Democrats thinking this is going to
be great for them it may be just the
opposite Harold in the green
room you said that the people who should
vote only should be on death row you
said you just want only death row voters
because they have nothing to lose you
share so much that I share green but you
have a problem with you have a problem
with teenage voters don't you well six I
think 16 is too young I'd agree with the
judge and that I think you you g you
gave some metrics we don't charge people
with crimes at that that young an agent
certainly uh you know do that do people
have a great enough understanding the
argument other side is that kids go to
school politicians lie every two years
or four years about how they're going to
improve the education system and uh we
the jury still lied actually the jury
decided they've not done that so I think
uh young people may have they don't pay
taxes may may have a case or some you
know some some people say that a lot of
people don't pay taxes the the the the
prison thing when you get out of prison
you should be able to vote I mean I
think there should be a restoration of
all one's rights if they serve their
time and pay their penalty right uh they
should they should that should all be
restored and that that's something we
can think four of us have agreed from
Dana here
well I'll take care of that Harold je
Louise away for a couple days thinks he
owns a table Dana Dana isn't the big
picture here it's not just it's not
about it's said that everything we're
doing these days is about criminals it's
like we don't hear about the we don't we
don't hear about the victims anymore
it's just like I I introduced a law I
don't know if you remember this where
victims get three votes you did yes it
was assault
me
so I think a couple things one I like it
that the states get to decide because I
think that makes up the our our system
best I also think that states should be
allowed to decide what to do about
repeat offenders right so if someone has
committed multiple felonies yeah and
they've given up their opportunity to be
a part of society then I don't know if a
state should say to do to give them
their rights back but I think the state
should be allowed to decide I also
believe
that at the age well the other thing is
sometimes these states will say yes you
can definitely get your rights back and
then they put all these barriers you got
to pay all these fines you got to do all
these things and that was one of the
things that happened in Florida there
was a referendum in the state the state
decided yes we want to allow felons to
have their opportunity to get their
voting rights back and then they started
to layer on all of these fees it went to
court that has pretty much largely been
taken care of when it comes to voting
age I'm for 18 for everything so
military voting drinking
smoking pot even though I hate smoking
pot whatever um alcohol wow but here's
the thing the Democrats are never
consistent they want to reduce the age
of voting to 16 but you can be a child
until you're 26 and be in your parents
healthare Insurance yeah that doesn't
make any sense it makes no sense at all
Dana I'm glad you brought that up hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now